the omicron which sounds like we're
being attacked by another galaxy uh now
we've seen might be being attacked by
another variant in south africa no good
deed goes unpunished they called up and
they said hey i'm seeing some variant
and it doesn't have the extreme symptoms
it might be evading the vaccine we don't
have that many cases just want to tell
you next thing you know a global travel
ban from eight to ten african nations
europe says shuts down everything and
southern goes wait a second what kind of
reaction is this is this the punishment
i get for telling you about doing
something that china never did and when
the president tried to ban and did ban
chinese trial china from the chinese
from traveling here he was called the
xenophobe now all of a sudden ban ban
everybody yeah they are banning eight
african countries you can't travel to
and from japan and israel ban foreigners
from visiting and morocco has suspended
all of their incoming flights for the
next two weeks because the doctors are
saying we'll know more in two weeks but
to your point brian that south african
doctor who identified this variant her
name is dr cotzie she says it's highly
transmissible so far cases are very mild
no one is seriously ill we'll know more
in two weeks we're not sure why there is
so much hype there's no reason she says
to panic
well uh there are
apparently there are 32 mutations that
could make it more
virulent and things like that they just
don't know dr fauci and the president
had a meeting yesterday in the oval
office along with the covet team and
they said essentially in two weeks we
may know more we will know more at uh
let's see 11 45 this morning the
president's gonna give us an update on
it and there's the team meeting
yesterday everybody's wearing a mask uh
an update on the omicron variant it's
interesting betsy mccoy
who used to be the lieutenant governor
here in new york state wrote an op-ed in
the new york post and she talks about
how you know lockdowns don't work but
travel restrictions do if they're put
quickly into place and you know on
wednesday a lot of the countries around
the world said you know what we're going
to cut off travel just to be safe dr
fauci said well we'll look into it she
says had he done it on wednesday when
the balance of the country the countries
around the world did
we might actually have been able to stop
it uh she said we already have a
three-day uh hold though if you come
from another country three days to get
uh to quarantine she said uh the study
of the journal of travel medicine found
that cutting off travel to china in 2021
australia averted a much larger pandemic
travel restrictions helped singapore
hong kong taiwan and south korea avert a
lot of carnage but dr fauci said you
know what
bowing to the world health health
organization he said you know what let's
just wait on that and he stopped it on
wednesday maybe things would be but see
here's the difference china didn't tell
us who was going to hit us
these guys are giving us a heads up on
what's coming to brace for it china
still hasn't told us what's going to hit
us now we have this thing called
vaccines we have therapeutics the
downside of lockdowns and bands now that
china still won't be transparent with us
but we have done reverse forensics on it
every time a doctor makes a move he
should have a psychologist and economist
right next to him because it's not just
shutting down because with that shuts
down lives livelihoods it puts people
shut down and puts them under mental
duress especially when this when these
symptoms are so small south african
president says that he's uh he says it
will further damage the economies of the
affected countries
three of them sitting together brian i
think you missed what i said in the very
beginning i said she said lockdowns
don't work but travel restrictions if
put into place quickly do what travel
restrictions have i i understand
but lockdown if the travel restriction
not locking down the people but but it's
shutting people out
if you are planning a trip let's say
next summer you have to buy insurance
trip insurance now absolutely because we
don't know what's going to happen if
they start shutting down countries with
every variant
by airlines or the hotels the people
that are associated with that the
livelihoods that go with that the
mortgage payments to go with the people
that work in the hotels the people that
have to pay rent to work in the hotels
the rent-a-car people that were renting
to people that could be coming over here
all this has to take into account
especially because when they say we know
nothing it's going to take two weeks to
decide but what we know is the symptoms
are a little mild and the other thing is
they only have 27
vaccination rate so how are you
comparing this to that and of course
they go back to their mantra boosters
and vaccinations so that's going to be
that's going to be joe biden's speech
today get a booster he's going to lean
forward he's going to whisper it he's
going to say get a booster get
vaccinated it's a patriotic thing to do
that's what dr fauci has been saying all
weekend listen to some of this
travel bans when you have a highly uh
transmissible virus never completely
would get the virus to coming
prevent it from coming into the country
no way that's going to happen but what
what you can do is you can delay it
enough to get us better prepared should
we expect to be seeing more lockdowns
again new lockdowns more mandates
you know i don't know george it's really
too early to say we just really need to
as i've said so often prepare for the
worst let's see what the information
that we're getting in real time tells us
and we'll make decisions based on the
science and the evidence the way we
always do but you want to be prepared to
do anything and everything
so you got to be prepared and we'll know
more he's going to say
through the president later today
in two weeks he should not be the lone
voice he has no credibility this is this
is terrible for the country he was
talking about science uh it is this is
empirical science two flights landed
friday in amsterdam from south africa
there were 600 passengers on board 10
percent tested positive for coronavirus
and of those 13 had omicron so it's out
there and it's spreading dr mccarrio
this morning was on fox and friends
first and he said he does think it's
probably here and it's definitely in
north america there are two cases in
canada but as far as exactly the united
states no cases have been at least
reported so far here there's huge uproar
in the czech republic because of this
and various european countries in
austria
australia's reviewing their reopening
plans so again you cannot have a doctor
alone without an economist and a
psychologist next to them and then the
political leaders will make the decision
from all three doctors can't be deciding
it because they're gonna say shelter in
place forever and when anthony fauci
won't even take in counter
counter voices they all speak in one
voice and if you speak up like dr scott
atlas does they try to minimize you and
marginalize you or worse yet associated
you with this horrible person called
donald trump he wrote a book about what
it exactly was like uh in the uh in the
medical unit of the administ previous
administration here's what he told it's
in his book but here's what he told
steve hilton last night
i've heard from south africa is that
it's not very lethal we don't i we don't
know i only know what i read uh about
this and what we what we hear from them
yes infections occur but it seems to be
a mild illness and you know we have to
be concerned we have to see what's going
on we have to watch the evidence but to
incite panic to introduce policies that
failed over and over and over again like
we never saw this fail before i mean the
lockdowns do not eradicate the virus
this is some
almost it's bizarre that we even have to
say this but there's some kind of
bizarre
myth among the governors the of the
world that somehow we can eradicate the
virus by the lockdowns the virus is not
going to be eradicated like that
well the virus did scare the stock
markets toward the end of last week the
stock market futures this morning are up
about an hour ago they were up about 200
and in other news merriam-webster the
dictionary company has officially come
out with the word of the year for 2021
covet
vaccine vaccine yes yes and those that
do say that they have it in in africa
they're saying i think they're younger
individuals they did lose taste and
smell and just feeling a little fatigued
right this isn't the bodies piling up in
india that we saw with the delta variant
does anyone know the difference between
the two i mean at the same time you
react you respond but you can't panic
the market drops 900 points everyone's
running for the hills now you have the
emergency declaration in new york no
more elective surgeries here i think up
until this uh starting on december 3rd
you know what that means in terms of
scans and what is going to the ripple
effect in terms of long-term health
people going to stop i guess getting new
hips and shoulders and
people have to think long term and this
governor who doesn't seem to know what
the heck she's doing makes governor
cuomo seem like desantis i think a lot
of people as of the fourth of july when
joe biden declared essentially that we
we beat and covet i think people are
just kind of beat down it's like oh no
here comes another one could be we'll
know more at 11 45 you'll see the
president live right here on fox right
after he meets with his coveted response
team i'm steve ducey i'm brian killman
and i'm ainsley earhart and click here
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis